hey guys good news i have a fitness app
you get to work out live with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on download feel on the app store or
go to fieldlife.com and start your
journey to become
good morning i'm a strong believer that
a short workout is better than no
workout i've put together a quick 15
minutes workout which you can do first
thing in the morning in your pajamas
this workout will boost your metabolism
and it will get your body to burn fat
more efficiently throughout the day you
don't need any weight if you have a
pillow grab a pillow so let's get ready
okay
there will be seven exercises in total
each workout will be for 45 seconds long
with 15 seconds rest in between so it
will work on your entire body and i will
also be adding in some gentle stretches
to really wake your muscles up so the
first workout will be a squat and a
press stand shoulder width apart if you
have a pillow grab a pillow what i want
you to do is curl the pillow up
squat down and as you come up press
straight up okay and then come back down
all right ready let's go curl the pillow
up squat down press straight up stretch
up back down and uncurl good so it's a
bicep curl and a shoulder press
and your goal is to squat as deep as
possible and bring both elbows to touch
your knees curl up straight up stretch
up back down and curl
again press straight up
lengthen your spine
and look straight ahead open up your
chest
looking straight ahead
waking
the muscles up good your glutes your
legs
your shoulders
as well
as your arms press up
and just relax all right now drop the
pillow
next workout will be lunge with a knee
driver okay so what i'm going to do is
stand
forward on your mat bring one leg back
and as you step back drive your knee up
bring it back down and drop your knee up
back down
and up so we're just working on one side
on the second set we will be changing
the other side so again look straight
ahead
engaging your core muscles bring it up
straight up drive it up
and squeeze
your glutes
good you should feel the work
on the right side of your glutes
your quads as well as your hamstring
drive it up
as you drive it up crunch your core
down
up
keep going
and remember to pace your breathing
and good shake it out now let's get down
onto the floor okay
what i'm going to do is a push-up with
rotation choose your option beginner you
can start on your knees if not get onto
your toes give me a nice push-up rotate
and open up on
one side and now change side
rotate stretch it
look straight up
nice good
and give
thanks to the beautiful day straight up
lengthen your spine
stretch it out
good push up
with rotation
and aim to bring your chest
as close to the mat
as possible
rotate find your balance
squeeze your belly
squeeze your belly and lengthen
good and now just drop your knees all
right next
downward dog with spiderman okay so
if you know downward dog it's a great
stretch
to really lengthen your entire body
start in a downward dog position what
i'm going to do is get into a plank
give me one
two spiderman to work on your oblique
back down into downward dog
down again
left
right
crunching on your oblique
stretch it out lengthen your spine
and now
stretch
good
breathe in hold it for two counts
into a plank
nice
bringing your knee to your elbow if you
can't reach it that's okay
all right
as you gain more flexibility and
strength
you will be able to reach your elbow
to your knee good and now just drop your
way
now let's get into a back roll okay so
what i want to do is start
at the edge of your mat
all right get into all fours
and now i want to inch forward
bringing again
your knee to your elbow
and now reverse
and crawl like a bear good so we're
working on all dimensions
good imagine your back crawling forward
crawling back
keeping your back flat
bring your butt down do not pike your
butt up too high keep it low
and keep crawling forward you don't need
a big space for this all right
just crawl to the edge of your mat
and drive it back
few more
keep going
last one
and now
right now let's get into a reverse plank
okay so
sit on your butt
get into a reverse plank position
what i want to do is drive your knee
to your chest crunch it in hold this
position crunch it in stretch it out
lift your butt up
and stretch it out okay so do not drop
your butt lift it up
bring your knee
close to your chest
drive it up stretch
hold it
if you feel your body shaking that is
absolutely
normal it means you're engaging your
entire body keep going drive it
knee to chest
bring it close
let's feel more
nice
keep going
breathe in breathe out
and one last final workout is going to
be plank
up down okay all right drop it
right let's get back into a high plank
position
i love plank up down because it really
works on your core at the same time it
works on your upper body as well okay so
now let's get from a high plank position
let's go low
and push yourself back up okay avoid too
much movement on your hips
press it back up
and back down what you can do is spread
your legs wider apart
to give you better balance down
and up good back down
and up so left right
right left
okay alternating between
your arms
down tighten your core suck your belly
in stay with me this is your final
workout and you will get a one minute
break
all right back down
push it up
and back down
okay
breathe in and out okay
that was just seven minutes of workout
but you should already
start to sweat a little bit
you should feel your heart rate
breathe
grab some water drink some water
and let's do another round all right
early morning workouts are meant to
boost your metabolism to give you more
energy throughout the day hence i've
combined strength training together with
a little bit of stretches to really
boost your metabolism
at the same time
it is not a high intensity workout where
you will feel too exhausted to even
start your day okay so let's start with
the first workout grab your pillow it's
going to be a squat and a press all
right grab anything you have in your
bedroom okay if you want more weights
lift heavier all right stay shorter with
the pot straight look straight ahead
let's curl up
bring it up press it up okay
drive your elbows
to your knees that doesn't mean you
should be hunching forward instead you
should be squatting low
enough okay and as you push up
push up with your heels drive it up look
straight ahead
chest up push up
down and uncurl
good
press it up
breathe in
who is ready to start your day strong
right after this you deserve a good
shower
not just yet
let me know in the comments below if
you're doing this workout in your
pajamas all right
drop the pillow knee driver so we
started on
our left leg just now so right now let's
bring our right leg back okay step
forward
start at the edge of your mat let's go
drive it back bring it up
good so now we're working on the left
side
look straight ahead
and keep your left arm close to your
body
good find your balance
bring it up
up squeeze as you come up squeeze in
your glutes
drive the knees forward good
drive it forward
down
swing your right arm
back
keep going
step back wide enough
and bring your legs
to a 90 degree position down
bring it up squeeze your glutes
and just relax right let's get down onto
the floor okay it's going to be a
push-up with rotation
choose your option
all right
i know most of us we hate push-ups but
push-ups are great for your upper body
so let's not skip this movement stretch
it out
good rotate
here's a tip
you can spread your fingers wider apart
and it will help with your balance okay
so you can spread
your fingers
wider apart to begin with
back down
rotate and twist on the other side
alternating good reach up look straight
up
if this is too much what you can do is
just
bring your arms
to your waist okay that's it
gently tap
and touch
if not
go all the way all right
next is going to be downward dog
with spiderman
i love this stretch it's so effective in
the morning it gets my blood flowing
throughout my body
okay so
let's start
in a downward dog position
back into a plank spiderman
okay
down stretch it out
and spiderman if you can't get your
heels onto the floor that's okay start
on your toes
to begin with as long as you feel the
stretch on your hamstrings okay that is
what we want
reach it
stretch on your hamstrings
on your back
and spiderman good last two more stretch
it out
one more stretch
and
just relax
okay now let's get into back row i am
sweating and that is what i want first
thing in the morning
i love to sweat okay
sweating and smiling to start your
morning let's go start at the edge of
your mat
and crawl forward okay
back
let me know in the comments below
if you want to
smile
and sweat to kick start your day
good job
let's get it going
start your day strong start your week
strong
how you start your monday
will determine the rest of your week
let's keep going
give thanks okay every morning take the
time
to list down three things you are
grateful for
last one more
forward
and
rest it out
okay now let's get into a reverse plank
sit down
all right
palms
fingers pointer forward okay not to the
sides pointer forward lift your butt off
okay on your heels
drive it in
knee to chest drive it in
squeeze your glutes
to keep your body up you have to squeeze
your glutes
and engage your core okay squeeze it
as close as you can crunch it
feel your abs good control do not rush
the workout
crunch and control
crunch it lift your butt up come on do
not drop it right now halfway there lift
it up
up
crunch it
point your toes forward
crunch keep going you are strong
let's go that's two more
one more on each side
and down
all right
who's ready for the final workout
and right after this you are done
you're gonna have a solid day let's go
start in a high plank okay
start in a high plank again spread your
fingers apart go low
and push up
low
and push up okay
minimal hip movement
up
and down
and you should be
stacking
your weight
in line with your shoulders
your palms
and your fingertips up
and down
press it up
and down breathe
your sweat
is your fat crying okay
this is the way to boost your metabolism
and to keep burning fat throughout the
day
and
you
are
done
all right
if you want to grab your pillow
i just want you to get into
a child's pose okay so gently relax your
arms
and just relax
your head on your pillow
you are not rushing
to go anywhere right now just give
yourself
that 15 minutes every morning
before you start your day okay
this is your time
breathe in
breathe out
and now just bring your right arm
under and across
and feel a deeper stretch
along your spine
change the other side
okay
good and now grab both the pillow
and i want you just to reach up
stretch it up
bring it as far back as you can
stretch it up okay
drive it as far back as you can
and now just bring it
over grab it with both arms behind you
and just lift
your arms up
stretch both arms
and
well done
i am sweaty my hair is messy but i feel
amazing if you do feel the same way do
leave your comments below give this
video a thumbs up
share it on and i know that
my day is going to be so much more
productive because i've started my
workout in the morning and i have no
more excuses and that is what i want for
you start your morning strong start your
morning productive and don't give
yourself any excuses so be sure to
subscribe to my youtube channel check
out my other workout videos
and my recipes as well as my health tips
and do also check out my fitness app
called feel on the app store as well as
the google play store where i'll be
sharing with you daily workouts all the
best